this is Startalk but your job now is
much different than it was in the
shuttle program I think because shuttle
shuttle flights were two weeks long and
and you know you had a lot to do you
worried about crew safety but now with
these missions no we mentioned in the
other segment that you know you could be
up there for as long as a year
and it was before we started the other
segment is somewhere yeah you've just
brought somebody home after almost a
year in for a year and it's so it's not
it's that's that's a whole different
equation so it's not just keeping them
safe and making sure the mission gets
done but it's also sort of the long-term
mental well-being keeping people engaged
and happy and keeping the crew going
morale is a is a is a big part of it too
and Emily you are the viewer the flight
director for the tail end of Scott
Kelly's year in space that write clean a
play alright so so you had the last I
guess the last three months of that
right expedition 46 so did was that was
that on your mind about trying to make
sure his mental health you know that he
is morality kept going and trying to
keep it light and fun for the whole team
what was that was that part of it for
you or was it approaches it was really a
concern is something that Scott and I
talked about before he launched you know
a whole year in advance his goal was for
Scott Stover his flight director when he
launched and myself to be able to
compare notes after he got back on the
ground and not be able to tell the
difference that we would have been
working with the same crew member and
honestly Scott is so even keeled and so
unperturbed all that that was really the
case so my personal strategy when I'm
about to take over because each of us
when we take over a leave for a mission
we're taking over for crew members that
are already on board because it's just
this continuous cycle of crew members we
never ever have the space station
without people living there
and so I will start sending them emails
upfront saying hey we're not gonna
change anything until they take over but
is there anything you'd like to tweak
what are you happy about what would you
like to do differently what is are there
any things we can tweak about what the
ground is providing for you to try and
listen to their needs and make sure that
we're providing them the ability to be
as efficient as they possibly can
because we get so much more work and
more productivity out of people in space
who are happy just like we get more
productivity out of people that are
happy on the ground can you give us an
example of any of those tweaks that they
asks you to make like without like
compromising see Scott actually didn't
ask for any I don't think we've had so
we have this whole kind of giant system
for how we managed that the crews day
they have we have this timeline that
shows in five minute increments what
they're gonna be doing from the time
they wake up until the time they go to
sleep and then the timeline tells them
okay it's time to be asleep and then in
addition to that we have a list of
activities that if they finish something
early here's a list of stuff it's just
kind of the honey-do list we need these
things done but they're not as important
so we haven't put them on the timeline
the way that we manage that there are a
lot of nuances if you can imagine
somebody else's building your calendar
every day then you might think that you
want your calendar managed one way and
then you start doing it for two months
and then say you know I really wish you
would make you would put my exercise in
the morning right I'd rather that we do
these kinds of things together and we do
these kinds of things alone so a lot of
what I tend to get is hey now that I've
been here for two or three months what
I'd really like is to change my strategy
for how you build my time and make it so
that I can execute a little more
efficiently through today and so a well
pointed and Scott Kelly say to you I
want to wear my gorilla suit in the
afternoon I and I when I'm in that room
I tend to be a little bit buried and I
tend to not necessarily know what's
going on in the out
world but that day I happen to be I
happen to get either emailed to me or
tweeted or whatever a link to the video
they can sit down I had no idea ahead of
time and so the next thing I do is call
Scott where did you get a gorilla suit
and how did you get that like this face
so yeah he managed to surprise us all
with that one so so what happened was
tell us a little bit we have a few more
seconds before go to the to the queries
you did so I saw this this is a very
famous video that went viral of the
astronaut in a gorilla suit right he's
like yeah so he put on this gorilla suit
and then he stuck himself inside my you
know an mo to baguette space booze big
white stowage bag yes a personnel so
he's sitting there and then pretend he
comes along and starts to open up the
bag and he jumps out of chasing Tim
Peake all around the space station and
it was really hilarious you should see
the The Colbert clip from what they did
on their opening I think that's where I
saw the first where I first saw the
whole gorilla thing in the first place
it was pretty adorable good fun and
games in space it's hard work but you
know what Emily said I think is really
important it's it's fun those things are
fun but it's also makes you more
productive keep them all up and key
that's it so it's if it's all just
drudgery work all the time even in space
it can get this so it's important to
keep keep it light as much as you can